manuel macro arroub est donc aujourd'hui
sur les terres de xavier bertrand pour
la clôture du bureau de la sécurité une
consultation débuter cette année entre
le gouvernement castex et les syndicats
de police plusieurs mois de concertation
pour améliorer leurs conditions
d'exercice mais aussi consolider le lien
avec les français pour en parler on
retrouve 4,6 à pique nique place beauvau
bon ce soir est-ce qu'il ya que retenir
de ces annonces des manuels macro
aujourd'hui
bonsoir stéphane est bien le président a
fait une dizaine d'annoncés avec une
volonté affichée de changer la donne il
faut dire que nos chefs d'état n'étaient
pas en terrain conquis 1 face aux
policiers aux gendarmes des hauts de
france et de xavier bertrand son
éventuel futur rival à la présidentielle
xavier bertrand qui avait fait qualifier
sa politique de sécurité intérieure
déchets que profond alors face à cette
critique et d'autre le président a
annoncé une loi de programmation pour la
sécurité intérieure qui sera présenté au
conseil des ministres au début de
l'année 2022 ce qui signifie évidemment
qu'elle ne sera pas prête avant la
présidentielle et emmanuel macron une
annonce importante veut davantage de
bleu comme il l'a dit sur le terrain une
présence de jour comme de nuit sept
jours sur sept et pour cela il faudra
évidemment réorganiser le temps de
travail et réaffecter des tâches il
souhaite également la mise en place de
plainte en ligne d'ici 2023 pour le
moment ce n'est pas possible à que
l'après plainte au niveau de la
formation ça s'éteint un moment
important de son allocution il souhaite
la renforcer pour qu'elle soit plus
longue et qualifiantes quatre mois de
plus s'est également renforcé la
formation continue de 50% toujours dans
ce domaine il souhaite la création d'un
centre de formation sur le maintien de
l'ordre en région parisienne pour les
policiers puisque de nombreuses
critiques ont été émises sur la question
du maintien de l'ordre particulièrement
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
toujours dans cette optique il y aura la
création d'une instance parlementaire de
contrôle des forces de l'ordre pour
procéder je cite à l'évaluation de leurs
actions une instance indépendante avait
en effet été réclamée par de nombreux
députés de l'opposition
et pour cela et bien emmanuel macron va
débloquer les moyens je vous propose de
l'écouter
en 2022 le ministère de l'intérieur
verra ainsi son budget augmenter de près
de 1,5 milliard d'euros dont 500
millions d'euros pour la mise en oeuvre
des premières mesures du beauvau de la
sécurité c'est sans précédent
95 %
95% de ces mesures qui ressorte du
beauvau sont pour du matériel de
l'investissement les conditions de
travail
autre annonce une simplification
drastique de la procédure pénale qui
était demandée par les associations et
les syndicats de policiers avec une
consultation du garde des sceaux à la
clé le déploiement de 30 mille caméras
piétons de bonne qualité pour éviter les
dérapages lors des interpellations
une réserve opérationnelle de la police
d'en doter de 30000 réservistes m créé
il y aura également une suppression du
rappel à la loi qui était a demandé par
les forces de l'ordre davantage
d'amendés forfaitaires sur le modèle de
celles qui sont dressés lors de la
consommation de cannabis et pour
terminer stéphanie la création de
nouveaux uniformes avec un polo
moderniser un calot pour remplacer la
casquette vous voyez stéphanie le
changement c'est maintenant apparemment
effectivement katia technique et un
discours